has lived across the street from
hitler's birthplace for some 50 years
and she's heard it all before
she thinks the matter has been blown out
of all proportion
in my opinion this house well
he only lived in that house for 14 days
he was just a baby
baby a baby
who would grow up to become the most
notorious criminal of the 20th century
austria's interior minister would just
as soon have hitler's birthplace torn
down
the owner has dropped out of sight and
remains unavailable for comment
not even brauno's mayor has ever
negotiated with her in person
now the state has decided to expropriate
the building
this expropriation is a bit dubious the
idea that a nation of laws like austria
can just expropriate a building
many people here are saying that's not
right
it's also the topic of discussion at
simbucks tobacco shop
what should be done with the hitler
house
even if they leave an open pit people
will still know what it used to be
postcards of hitler's house are for sale
here ostensibly because of the memorial
stone in front
it was brought here from mount housing
concentration camp as a reminder of the
crimes of nazism
martin simbuck thinks the building
itself can serve that purpose
this house the building shouldn't be
torn down
but used in a responsible way
to educate people about history and work
against fascism
for historical and academic work
several of his customers also oppose the
interior minister's
they just plans to tear it down to keep
the idiots from gathering there every
april 20th
the die hard fanatics but there are
other ways to stop that
you don't have to tear the building down
but the government wants to keep the
house from becoming a place of
pilgrimage for right-wing extremists
even if they've been showing up less
frequently they don't limit their
appearances to hitler's birthday april
the 20th
the ikg jewish community in vienna also
sees demolition as the best solution
nobody can say how the ownership of this
building might develop in the future
or how the local political structure
might develop
but once the building is torn down it's
gone
and can't be rebuilt them
tearing it down would not be as final as
it seems some political analysts see
that solution more as sweeping the
problem under the rug
it'd be like a death sentence for the
building but if i just blew it away
i wouldn't have the opportunity to
re-socialize it to deal with it
andreas meislinger is calling for
hitler's birthplace to be redefined as a
house of responsibility
where young people from all over the
world can learn about brawnow and delve
into their own history
he's collected over four thousand
supporters for his initiative over the
internet
but hitler's birthplace isn't braunau's
only problem
the name itself recalls the brown
uniforms of the nazi party members and
the sa
some people would prefer to rename the
town rolled rod steiger is just as much
against that idea as she is against
tearing down the house where hitler was
born
it won't change history it would be nice
if you could just tear down a building
and change history
but i see no point in it besides what
would they put there
no one can answer that question yet
prana will continue to search for a way
to rid itself of the ghosts of its past